herzlich willkommen zu einem brandneuen
format in dem dave und ich gegeneinander
antreten
wir kriegen jede folge eine aufgabe die
wir sofort erledigen müsse viel spaß mit
unserer ersten aufgabe viel spaß mit
gross hat mich gebeten euch eine aufgabe
für eure erste folge go zu stellen und
da bin ich natürlich gerne behilflich
auch wenn euch das ergebnis alles andere
als gefallen wird geht jetzt sofort zum
auto im auto für zwei von mir für euch
vorbereitet rucksäcke und fahrt zu den
koordinaten die sich ebenfalls
geschickter aber let's go ich weiß nicht
was hier abgeht wir sind wirklich
irgendwo im wald angekommen und guck mal
hinter mir bitte ich hab mir das gut
sehen können ich fühle mich wie so ein
adventure blogger alter wir müssen noch
ein bisschen runter ich befürchte dave
dass sie vielen koordinaten unten am see
sind leute guckt euch das mal an es ist
ja sehr schön aber würde es nicht so
regnen was soll's wir laufen noch mal
kurz hin und dann befürchte ich wenn wir
wahrscheinlich irgendwie unser
nachtlager oder so aufschlagen ich habe
euch ja gerade schon mal den rucksack
gezeigt und ihr habt eine angel gesehen
habt ein schlafsack gesehen wir sind an
einem see was soll schon passieren außer
dass wir jetzt hier irgendwo kennen
müssen und dann uns irgendwie versorgen
müssen um über die nacht zu kommen
schauen wir mal wie findest du das
wetter zum campen ist das mega ist dass
wir hier so unseren schlaf sagt der hand
wahrscheinlich warm halten soll im regen
herumtragen weil wir immer noch nicht da
wo wir hin mit aber nicht mehr weitere
200 meter und auf der dave hast du es
okay der fachleute ich sehe sind also
bei den kunden angekommen sehr gut packt
jetzt die rucksäcke aus die challenge
endet morgen um 12 wer bis zum ende
durchhält bekommt den ersten punkt das
ist scheinbar der platz an dem sich die
heutige challenge cup spielt die erste
challenge abspielt und was soll da bitte
noch alles kommt wenn das der einstieg
ist
wir sind einfach in so ein fucking weit
okay schauen wir einfach gerade schon
sein rucksack bei sich geöffnet ich
glaube draußen haben wir ungefähr das
gleiche da ich habe hier im schlaf sagt
er lacht ja schon ziemlich nass geworden
ist habe ich meinen rucksack mit dem
equipment unter den baum gelegt damit
weil das nicht nass wird aber der ist
schon mal nach perfekt ich glaub das
wird ein gemütlicher nach wir haben eine
angelfreunde ich hab mal einen
angelschein gemacht das war vor lass
mich nicht lügen acht oder neun jahren
du hattest bei dir ein bisschen was zu
essen drin also bis dato sieht alles
genau gleich mal diesen klitschen aus
dem schlafsack nach hinten und öffne mal
hier vorne gaskartusche stimmt das
ponton ja ja ja dass man dort zu deinen
rucksack inhalt ein messer ich glaube
das ist wirklich gold wert eine flasche
wasser eineinhalb liter die challenge
geht bis morgen um 12 das heißt nicht so
super viel auf jeden fall für den
gaskocher so ein aufsatz dass wir da
wahrscheinlich eintopf oder sowas auch
darauf macht der topf ist auch hierbei
genau wie bei dir eine hängematte wir
werden uns hier in der hängematte
aufspannen und einfach zwischen den
bäumen in der luft
das ist so wichtig damit wir nicht auf
dem kalten nassen boden liegen das ist
wirklich ein lifesaver für die komplette
nacht 100 prozent das ist die plane die
wir wahrscheinlich benutzen können um
uns irgendwie ab zu spannen genau das
sei mit dem wir alles befestigen und
ansonsten hier leisten licht für den
nach dem träger genau wie bei ihr
das ist die brille die wir anziehen
werden als die brille des triumph schade
dass du warst ja nicht wer diesen
formaten und nachts wenn wir uns
trainieren aber ich meinen jahren darum
gebeten wir wollten krasse challenges
haben wir jetzt wirklich bekommen das
ist ein gebührender start für diese
serie glaube ich mache schon mal die
planer auf und legte über meine sachen
[Applaus]
der app store hängt schon mal ich glaub
heißt das in fachkreisen von mir hängt
noch gar nichts ich habe dave geholfen
dh dave wird so nett sein mir auch zu
helfen obwohl wir gegeneinander antreten
werde der einzige sein der morgen um 12
uhr noch hier im wald ist du wirst
aufgeben
das ding hängt wir brauchen jetzt nur um
die enten zu befestigen heringe haben
wir nicht wissen wir also selbst
herstellen aus stecken weil sonst gibt
es hier nicht ich habe den großen stock
gefunden den ich mir einigermaßen gleich
groß gebrochen habt hoffe er ist nicht
zu morsch und daraus heringe zu machen
aber versucht jetzt einfach das
funktioniert sehr gut könnt euch mal
ganz kurz an was hier für eine krasse
maserung im holz ist crazy so muss das
aussehen wenn man gespannt ob dave das
auch so gut hinbekommen das hat da vorne
und besucht das gleiche wie ich sehr gut
leute ich bin fertig und du hast mal
deine jährigen gesehen
das sind small heringe dass wir perfekt
hier trocken von sowas hier werden wenn
heute nacht ein start weg legt heute
dass es ehrlich anstrengend ich sage ich
freue mich so krass auf diese spaghetti
und so wir haben auf jeden fall eine
dreiviertelstunde die sonne untergeht
haben sollten uns daran halten könnte
mir gerne mal in die kommentare
schreiben ich denke die meisten von euch
sind keine outdoor-spezialisten glaubt
ihr würdet euch das zum trauern ich weiß
ehrlich gesagt nicht wie ich geantwortet
hätte mich dass jemand einfach normalen
als man jetzt hier so ein stein als
faustkeil geholt auf steinzeitmensch
angelehnt und werde ihr damit meine
hering in den boden hauen
ganz wichtig freunde wir lassen ja
natürlich nicht also gar keinen fall
irgendwas liegen
es ist schon klar wenn man irgendwie den
wald genutzt dass man dann auch sie
sorge tragen muss dass man ihnen so
wiederfindet wie wir ihn vorgefunden
haben jetzt geht es an die hängematte
aber ich glaube die hängematte
hoffentlich schneller auf gehangen als
die tabs aber die hängen dafür wirklich
glaube ich bombe und hier können wir
nachts über bleiben ich habe es so einen
hunger bei das ist so anstrengend wie
einmal hier rausholen einfach das gehört
zur hängematte die verpackung sogar zwei
fette seile sehr gut weil sonst hätten
wir keine seele mehr hier nicht
erpressen ende hast du eine von den
sachen wo man es schafft auszupacken
aber nie wieder das eingesät hier ich
habe hier vorne schon mal an einem von
diesen löchern aufgehangen die
befestigen wir mit diesen seien dann um
den baum herum nur wie ich bin 43 meter
abstand habe ich glaube das passt oder
um den baum herum mega sie an der
hängematte ist viel schwerer
seht ihr das hier dass die hängematte
ich probiere es jetzt auch auf die
gefahr hin dass ich mich übelst aufs
maul hauen
mein gott oh mein gott
also ich sitze ja tut das auch gut zu
sitzen nach der ganzen scheiße ich habe
jetzt gesehen wie ich die hängematte
aufgegangen habe sie hängt ich hoffe es
bleibt auch die nacht über so wenn wir
später rein links jetzt hätte ich
erstmal dave das seiner auch hängt okay
leute ist es ziemlich dunkel hier drin
schon verrät ein bisschen unterwegs habe
mich umgeschaut und das schlagartig
dunkel geworden wir sind jetzt aber
vorne am wasser und ufer eingesät schon
es wird heller
das gaben jetzt will ich die letzten
zehn minuten des tages um uns noch mal
auszuprobieren mit unserer angriff und
uns hier unsere fertig essen aufzuwärmen
aber guckt euch das bitte einmal an
komplett krass wir probieren uns auch
nicht nur einen sondern haben uns eine
drohne von einem kumpel ausgelegt und
das machen wir sind also seht den
patronen aufnahmen viel spaß
[Musik]
ja die ganze zeit die ganze zeit die
sonst sicher wir können echt glück
währenddessen mache ich hier mal ein
grill fertig aber das ist ziemlich
einfach der körper sich ihr das jetzt
viel dreck
ich habe das gefühl die befürchtung dass
das nicht zusammen funktioniert dieses
teile oben und das hier unten freunde
als ob wir das jetzt nicht zusammen
benutzen können ist das irgendwie ein
schlechter scherz
wenn ja ist ja nicht sehr lustig der ist
es kommt das gefecht ist einfach mast
exclusively mit camping gas cartridges
firma vor das war absicht von sebastian
ja ich könnte es wirklich sein wenn ja
ganz ehrlich über seine hand über seine
wir haben uns den arsch abgearbeitet das
war so anstrengend die sachen daran
aufzuhängen und jetzt müssen wir hungrig
schlafen oder wie in diesem schönen
szenario hier mit der drohne mit schrot
klingt wie dick sie gleich abstützen das
ist mal ganz ehrlich sagen auch wenn wir
uns hier abpacken auch wenn das wirklich
keine leichte aufgabe war bisher und wir
kein essen haben ist das einfach ein
geiler moment darf auch wenn wir
gegeneinander sind muss ich ehrlich
sagen das mega heiß und ich bin mega
freut euch sowas erleben kann mit
youtube stellte mir vor leute ich habe
jetzt gerade mein studium fertig würde
ich jetzt normalerweise sein wenn ich
kein youtube machen würde wahrscheinlich
in irgendeinem büro von irgendeine
agentur sitzen und den ganzen tag lang
mails schreiben und sonst was ich glaube
es für zeit trocken ich spaghetti
bolognese zu probieren
ich bin ganz ehrlich glaube es für
zucker riechen oh mein gott walther guck
mal hier rein leute ihr seht hier sind
so kleine baby nudeln drin und es riecht
so unglaublich lecker nehmen jetzt
einfach mal eine nudeln gekocht
ganz ehrlich es ist irgendwie trotzdem
fucking lecker gerade so trockene nudeln
zu kauen überhaupt irgendwas jetzt will
jeder etwas zu essen dreimal an der
wirklichkeit alleine dieses dieses
pulver da drin glaubt werden um kranke
magenschmerzen wenn wir das nennen ja
aber wir werden überleben
dass man ein bisschen schmecken vor
allem sind unsere klamotten so leicht
angeschnitten das bedeutet uns ist kalt
und wir gehen gleich in die nacht
geschützten klamotten kann manchmal
fragt wahrscheinlich hätten wir unsere
sachen ausziehen soll beim arbeiten ja
100 prozent ich glaube allgemein dass es
so übels der kasse lernprozesse ist die
ganzen leute die gerne in wald gehen und
gerne genau sowas machen lernen jedes
mal ein bisschen was dazu und dass man
auch ein bisschen den reiz aus so
einfach schon halb leer
er hatte so dumpf klingt cup team zurück
aufgelöst und es geht zunehmend schwer
herunter
da hab ich bewahre mir den rest jetzt
auch dass frauen was zum frühstück ab
wie soll dieses vom
weiter gehen ich weiß echt nicht dass
man leute mehr probiert jetzt allen
ernstes hier
ich muss einfach dein schicksal
akzeptieren ist genau was deine packung
aber wichtig dass es wirklich einfach
sein mit eigentlich lauten stadt auch so
bis morgen um 12 uhr
es wird vielleicht harz wird vielleicht
unangenehm aber die sache ist mir wird
nicht kalt ich bleibe hier nicht sitzen
sondern ich werde nicht gleich ganz
entspannt in die hängematte zurückziehen
und ein bisschen den geräuschen des
weins zu hören und zwar nicht nur
zwischen bekommst du nicht
ich glaube ich gehe jetzt mal langsam
wieder zurück in den wald und mache mir
da mal gemütlich und leuchtet ja mal ein
bisschen von meiner handykamera
es ist nämlich wirklich verdammt dunkel
[Musik]
nichts absolut gar nicht ich möchte mich
mal hier ein bisschen mit meinem handy
an was ist fucking gruselig heute möchte
damit ein bisschen happy dass wir direkt
nebeneinander wenn jetzt hatte ich hier
noch mehr spaß aber ich zeige euch mal
wir haben die lage aussieht werde ich
irgendwelche tiere sind die seen halt
5000 besser als irgendwie unglaublich
genommen haben ist ein bisschen gruselig
er im glühwürmchen
oh mein gott das war mir zu gruselig
wieder er ganz ehrlich es ist fucking
große leere recht laut aber ich bilde
mir schon einen grunzen gehört haben die
sache ist wir waren gemeinsam auf einem
campingtrip also camping das ist ja kein
camping ja das ist ja überleben aber als
wir beim camping trip waren sind in der
nacht wildschweine an unseren wenn
gekommen ich hätte nicht glücklicher
gewesen sein könnte dass wir in fucking
wenn drinnen waren wo die dinger nicht
rein können und dass sie schnell wieder
weg waren und dass sie schnell wieder
weg war
wir wollen eigentlich schlafen und wir
waren andere setzen dh wenn es in der
nacht anfängt um uns herum zu grunzen
alter ich schwöre ich glaub ich raste
aus
seid ihr bereit mit mir gemeinsam das
ufer zu erkunden das jetzt früher das
ganze mal so ein bisschen zu filmen hier
sehen könnt risi den edelstein ich kann
ihn einfach verkaufen und dave umbringen
lassen sich die challenge gewonnen aber
er merkt schon leute langsam ist das
hier ein bisschen vorbei mit dem ganzen
spaß und der freude
es wird dunkel der probiert noch zu
eigentlich weiß ehrlich nicht was er
machen will aber
ich habe ein bisschen ihr habt checken
was los ist sagte für die ich mich ein
bisschen sicherer
die nehme ich auf jeden fall mit
vogel verschrecken der hat noch nicht so
wirklich schluss aber ich hab' ich weiß
du willst dass wir gewinnen ich werde
nicht abbrechen aber ich habe ein
angebot für dich okay siehst du das
siehst du wie dieser stein hier gelebt
hat ja der ist bestimmt ein paar
millionen wert schätze würdest du kannst
du mich noch weiter verarbeiten aber
dafür müsst du ihn erst mal akzeptieren
die einzige kleine bedingung dafür ist
dass du jetzt aufgibst ja ja perfekt ist
ein vertrag
wenn ihr jemanden anschauen wollte er
beim angeln versagt haben vor der wahl
direkt auf den channel
die folge ist natürlich jetzt auch
machen ich hoffe morgen recht früh wach
sein ich erinnere mich auch von einem
campingtrip daran als ich einmal linken
war nachts aus dem werden rausgegangen
den wald gegangen bin angestanden
fucking wildschein ich bin nach hinten
gegangen gerecht dass wir schon auch
also alles gut ausgegangen war
wildschweine sind denn nur dann
gefährlich wenn sie frischlinge haben
also kinder und er weiß auch wie in
deutschland unterwegs
die fristen
ich hoffe auf jeden fall das wenig
begegnen falls es so ist und ich bin
froh wenn ich in meiner hängematte
liegen ihr das sieht aus wie der eingang
zu einem gemütlichen schlafplatz
ich finde nicht aber das ist ja eingangs
unseren straßen
danach bin jetzt hier unter meinem zelt
hoffe ich mal dass ist eine ruhige nacht
wird aber ganz ehrlich sind so viele
geräusche hier schon mal ein bisschen
wohl zu sein
der wald nicht gestört wird
war da was
freunde
[Musik]
jetzt schnell pinkelt wirklich sofort
zurück das ist das eine
das
[Musik]
[Applaus]
als als gut hier ist als battle ich
komme nicht mehr aus
naja ich kam runter gefallen
ja die seite hat gehalten die wir einmal
fest und so den bogen alter ja freunde
perfekt diese kleine nervensäge hier
drüben da kommt jetzt rein und sie haben
mich an dich und mich beim zweiten
versuch einzusteigen zu film gucken wir
mal ob das jetzt vielleicht was wird
anhalten
mit willkommen
ja ich habe schon ich lieg endlich
wieder ich habe meine essentials bei mir
das einzige es dave hat mir kein
bisschen geholfen aber ich habe hier
alles was ich brauche für die nacht und
seht hier das sind 14 grad zwölf grad
werden sollten acht und der schlaf ist
für zehn grad ausgelegt das heißt
dürften nicht zu kalt werden
ich frage mich jetzt ein schön noch ein
bisschen und dann das hält dann hoffe
ich dass die nacht schnell vorbei ist
weil es wirklich ein bisschen rundlicher
den ganzen geräuschen aber das wird
schon
und ich weiß ja noch was wir jetzt genau
mitternacht und das sind die ganze zeit
irgendwelche crazy geräusche
sind gar nicht so dunkel ist aber ein
bisschen was sehen und fahrrad war nur
dass hier ungestört das hatten wir
bisher schon recht einiges abverlangt
muss ich wirklich sagen dass ich das
symbol für ein kartenhaus weiter
das war 2008 wenn ich diese hängematte
da nicht wieder dran kriege was mache
ich dann nicht aufgeben müssen
das ist mir egal ob dave und ich
gewinnen oder ob nur ich gewinne
aber ich will auf jeden fall nicht
aufgeben guten morgen freunde
dave ist leider auch war das nicht nach
hause gegangen er ist leider auch nicht
abgestürzt so wie ich und ich würde auch
nicht alle anderthalb stunden wach
geworden ich habe ihm durchgestellt
ich sag's euch ganz rechts kommt
überhaupt nicht in frage dass ich vor
zwölf uhr nach hause fahre deshalb würde
ich sagen man langsam gemütlich
aufstehen dann aber ich noch die
restlichen nudeln ja das wird ein
traumhafter morgen los geht's hier habe
ich die nacht verbracht hängt schon
recht tief will gar nicht wissen wie es
außer mit mir drin so der jetzt hoffe du
bist jetzt auch endlich mal fertig
machen auf unseren papst auch mehr viel
wasser weil es durch die ganze nacht
über die latent geregnet und die ganze
zeit so ein bisschen halt ich glaube
dass auch raus geschafft aus dem blogger
eine dreiviertelstunde stunde drin
gelegen und jetzt bin ich hier draußen
und was sehe ich hier mit gopro im mund
viermal ist weiter dave das wasser ist
übertrieben war
im werk gleich dass wir ein bisschen
langweilig ist es ist kurz vor acht
mittlerweile aber ich weiß nicht so
richtig was ich noch machen soll
es ist nicht so als wäre es besonders
unangenehm oder ich hatte hunger oder so
ich habe ja auch die hälfte von meinen
nudel aber es ist einfach langweilig wie
ihr seht sind wir hier an diese dinge
guck mal was hier vorne liegt glaube das
ist man sieht hier vorne so die fühler
glaube das war irgendeine art languste
also ein minium oder soja tatsächlich
hier vorne liegt der schwanz hat sich
aber jemand puma gegönnt hier day fällt
es dir gelingen sollte eine languste zu
angeln können wir vielleicht feinste
langusten schwenzel mit knoblauchbutter
zum frühstück essen
ich werde jetzt schnitzen gegen lw so
langweilig ist mir gerade freunde
[Musik]
masala ist das kapitel 14 wir gehen noch
mal zu unseren hängematten packen alles
zusammen stehen und noch mal ein
bisschen rein aber das ende ist das
jeden fall jetzt in sicht und fühlt sich
auch gut an das ist sind sich der
neuburger ich glaube ich für so einen
fetten mittagsschlaf endlich schlaf
mittag darüber aber wir uns auf jeden
fall durchgezogen dass das wichtigste
zeit zusammen zu packen
ihr seht vor eine 11 uhr 28 gefühlte
ewigkeit aber es war auch richtig schön
in der natur deshalb irgendwie klar ich
würde sagen ich mache mich jetzt daran
abzubauen als erstes sind habt an die
hängematte und dann war es das auch von
unserem abenteuer hier von der ersten
folge nächsten folgen werden mindestens
genauso krank haben wir es geschafft
einen negativen punkt hat die sache
nicht leichter als einen positiven punkt
hat es auch bei der nächsten tag sagt
sie ich dich ab